That is what's going on. You're right,
Jar. You have a very good read,
actually. Very good read. This guy's
This guy's brain needs to be collected
for science.
We got to know what's going on in there.
After all, Nicholas is a good boy, and
he wouldn't do anything Daddy wouldn't
like. Is it almost endearing when Jar
does it? I think it's I think it might
almost be endearing when Jar when Jar
does it. Nick is a fat kid with
prescription glasses. Where's the aura?
Where's the aura at all? Just a robot.
Famous Cincy Bear defender. If you
remember all that drama, he he called
into Chud's about a video that he made
defending Cincy Bear in the center of
Chud trying to get him to review. And he
had a like huge blow-up over it.
Everyone was laughing at him. It was all
awesome. Anyway, that's like 2 years ago
now. Basically, it's just an autistic
ACC YouTuber who is criticized a lot for
making videos by committee. He doesn't
really put his own opinions into videos.
He asks people in the ACC like Lyra
Convoy what his take should be, and
that's how he he makes the videos. He's
now released a video called Nicholas
DiOrio versus Chud Logic Commentary
Civil War. So, we're going to take a
look at this. Obviously, topic we're
massively interested in. So, I want to
know Jar's take. I got to know what
Jar's take is.
[__] Slome, Daddy's home. Get ready for
another exciting episode of Just the
Joobot.
Wow, this is a great start, I got to
say.
W Jar.
What was that imagery just then? What
was that imagery on screen just then?
>> [music]
>> Is it just the Chud check? What's in the
background?
What is this conveying?
So, the drama community is in another
civil war for the 18th billionth time.
It's basically between Chud Logic and
his supporters versus Nicholas DiOrio
and his supporters. And it all got
started over the Turkey Tom allegations
and H3H3. No, I am not joking.
>> [groaning and screaming]
>> Let's begin with a little background
starting with H3H3, aka Hey, great
start. Ethan is one of the most
well-known and oldest people in the
drama community. I'll give you $2. This
guy has been making drama videos for
over a decade now. He got into a drama
with LeafyIsHere and Pyrocynical. After
that, he started rubbing shoulders with
some of the biggest people in the
anti-SJW community. Over time, he became
more and more of a leftist and disavowed
a lot of the old anti-SJW videos he
made. Unsurprisingly, this caused a lot
of people to turn against him. Several
people called him a snake and a liar
during his drama with LeafyIsHere. And
now people were calling him a snake and
a liar again. H3 became an enemy to keep
Yeah, I don't think he was ever quite
leftist, but sure thing. No problem.
several Leafy clones, anti-SJW,
anti-woke YouTubers, and even the
commentary bros. But luckily for Ethan,
he was still chummy with a lot of
breadtubers such as Hasan [__]
Podcasting with one another made them
both even more successful than they used
to be. But then a war on the other side
of the planet between backwards desert
people happened, and this caused the
friendship of Ethan and Hasan to end.
Ethan then got into drama with Hasan and
his friends, and this caused a lot of
his old enemies
>> his old enemies to start joining him.
>> [__] sake, man. Yep, you heard me
right. The commentary bros, the
anti-woke YouTubers, and everything in
between all started backing H3H3 because
they hated Hasan [__] more. I guess the
old saying is true, the enemy of my
enemy is my buddy. But there was one
person in the commentary bros who backed
H3 more than anyone else, and that was
Saint Nicholas DiOrio, a man even fatter
than Santa Claus himself. You see,
around this time the Destiny drama was
happening, and since Nick could no
longer orbit Destiny, Wait.
Is Jar cooking?
Is this going to be an awesome video?
I'm going to like nothing started out
like crazy like, "Oh, this is totally
retarded." And now he's like pinning
Nick. He's like actually pinning Nick.
Exactly. That is what's going on. You're
right, Jar. You have a very good read,
actually. Very good read.
orbit H3H3 instead. It's kind of ironic
that this big fat Jack Horner-looking
[__] is the one orbiting people
instead of the OTHER WAY AROUND. DIE
DUBS WITH THE BULL. SPEAKING OF THE
Destiny drama, Chud Logic accused Tom of
being a sweeper right to his face. Yeah,
we should wrap this Destiny thing up
though before we get completely clipped
if we don't actually engage in the
discussion.
I mean, what are we supposed to say? We
don't really know what went on.
Yeah, it's I guess that's kind of the
main thing. It's like I don't really
know what's going on there. I mean, it's
it's it's it's Yeah, when the class
[__] [__] volunteers to read, but he
can actually read the words.
Actually gets it out. It's like perfect.
It's like everyone's sitting there.
Everyone's sitting like, "Fuck. Fuck."
And it's just like the most eloquent
complex passage you've ever heard. He's
like, "Wow, damn. Damn." [laughter]
And it's slow clapping.
Okay. Okay. Can we stop this [__]
sweeping, please? It's pretty [__]
obvious what went on, isn't it? There
wasn't There wasn't [__] consent.
It's obvious, bro. Wait. It's [__]
obvious, dude. It's So, when Spider
comes out with a good tweet. It's
obvious.
Okay. Chud Logic, let's talk about it.
Chud Logic, let's talk about it. What do
you mean it's obvious? Bro, the sweeping
is unbelievable. I heard it, but I
didn't know it was true. Tom's sweeping
with Destiny again, bro. Here we go.
Here we go. Not going to lie, this is
pretty based, but it did somewhat piss
off
>> [laughter]
>> the others. Okay, W Jar.
He's on the team.
including Nicholas DiOrio for sucking
off Ethan Klein. I'm not putting up
Nicholas DiOrio's stream. I'm not making
it about any one individual, okay? I
don't [__] care about your gay camp.
This is also really Do you know what Do
you know what Whilst we're here, I'll
also say this as well. I'm so [__]
sick of you utter cretins desperately
trying to [__] throw a wedge between
me and DiOrio because he's cock-sucking
Ethan Klein at the moment, okay? That's
That's about Stahli and me, by the way.
That's about Stahli and me. are so
[__] You're like raping my brain with
this [__] That's what you wanted to do,
the 20th stream sucking off Ethan Klein.
Yes, I'm talking about you, Nicholas
DiOrio, okay? Nick confronted Chud in
private about this, and they somewhat
talked things out.
>> Now, listen. I will be fair. I know what
people in Chud thinking and they're
going to say, okay? But my concern,
ladies and gentlemen, is There's There's
There's
There's some definitely
racial element to this with Chud. Some
old white guy It's like when when when
the young black guy comes into his chat
and makes fun of him, he feels the need
to start start like dancing to that
tune. Do you know what I mean? There's
something going on here. It's like sort
of like the beans copy pasta, you know,
the the beans in the beans all eating
cars
copy pasta. It's like, you know, he It's
that It's that same
psychic trauma,
you know,
getting mocked by by black kids.
>> [laughter]
>> The big sweep might be on, okay? The mid
The big sweep might be on. Gotta sweep
sweep sweep.
>> I am not participating in the big sweep.
>> Yes, this was directed at Nick and the
other commentary bros. We know this
because he said this right after reading
out a post from Nick. Nick just
responded. Increase the volume of the
video. nothing of what has occurred
tonight, but my understanding is that
Half Baked is on hiatus for a little
while, so we'll see in the next couple
of days where that goes. Nick DiOrio
states that Half Baked, his podcast with
Tom and Lord Vegan, is going on hiatus
for a while, but it could be DM's.
Here's the thing with this, okay?
Anyone that wants to claim that this is
a nothing burger, why the [__] is the
podcast going on hiatus, dude? If this
is nothing to worry about, nothing to be
concerned about, why is the podcast
going on hiatus? A few weeks later, Tom
responded to these allegations and
completely proved himself innocent.
Thanksgiving came a little early, but
this turkey was not on the menu. Around
the same time, Chud was going on
vacation, and Nicholas DiOrio took a few
jabs at Chud Logic during his Turkey Tom
coverage. Nicholas took a few more jabs
at Chud about halfway through his
follow-up Turkey Tom video.
It was just him regurgitating stuff he
said previously and also clarifying a
few things. Despite Nick not directly
making a video on Chud, just taking jabs
at him in his Turkey Tom video, it still
caused Chud to lose roughly 600
subscribers. I want to make it clear
that neither Chud nor Nicholas has
directly made a video on the other
person, at least not yet. But when Chud
came back from vacation, he was pissed.
Bro seemed more traumatized than the US
Vietnam vets. Nicholas DiOrio somewhat
looked pathetic for cutting off his
friendship with Chud publicly over such
a small reason. Oh, no, he said the big
sweep might be on. Now, I understand
that was not the only reason. It was
just a straw that broke the camel's
back. It's kind of like when you
domestically abuse your partner over
something small like forgetting to buy
tin foil at the store. Obviously,
What I I just Seriously, what When this
guy dies,
take his brain.
Study it for science, okay? This guy's
This guy's brain needs to be collected
for science.
We got to know what's going on in there.
[laughter]
over such a small reason. Oh, no, he
said the big sweep might be on. Now, I
understand that was not the only reason.
It was just a straw that broke the
camel's back. It's kind of like when you
domestically abuse your partner over
something small like forgetting to buy
tin foil at the that's something small
that no one would attack another person
over, but that's not why you're actually
doing it. [__] had it coming for a lot
of different reasons. But of course, the
officer is not going to see it that way.
He's just going to come up to you and
say, "So, you beat your wife over tin
foil? Are you Are Uh-huh. you serious?"
So, Chud did have an easy win here.
Unfortunately, like a Democrat candidate
who has a clear path of victory right in
front of them, he refused to get out of
his own way. He spent a lot of time
spurging at his own chat. You mad at an
attack when he was sleeping.
What? What are you on about? I mean,
I don't even think that was wrong about
Biden. He's saying
Biden should have gotten out of the way
earlier because Democrats would have an
easy chance of victory.
That's that
I don't even disagree that political
take. This is actually quite This is
quite possible for Fidger. This is quite
high-level for Fidger. I'm going to be
honest.
God, you guys do not [__] get it.
It's so transparent. Bro, you commentary
[__] viewers literally should be sent
to the [__] glue factory, bro. It is
insane how [__] you are. There's
this insane narrative that's been
perpetuated about me. None of these
retards have actually watched my
coverage, and they're just angry at me.
How about addressing the questions
people are asking instead of just
calling them [__] What do you mean?
I'm addressing the questions, dude. I'm
addressing all of them.
I'm malicious.
What do you mean?
How am I being malicious? What do you
mean?
What do you mean, bro? What do you mean?
Huge tirade. So, he talked a little
[__] Stop being in your feelings.
Okay, this is [__] cope, dude. He
launched a [__] deranged [__]
what? 40-minute segment or something, I
saw, talking about me and talking [__]
about me when I was on holiday, when I
was away. And it's all stuff he could
have spoken about before I went away.
Some people tried to defend this by
saying things like, "Oh, he was just
playing things up. He wasn't actually
that upset." Well, guess what? Acting
like an idiot still makes you an idiot.
Also, I really don't think he was
playing things up. Chud then came up
with one of the most paranoid bizarre
conspiracies I have heard in a very long
time. He came to the conclusion that Tom
intentionally delayed his response to
serious rape allegations so Nick could
cover it and bash Chud while he was on
vacation so he couldn't immediately
respond.
>> think that's a crazy conclusion. I was
saying I don't think it's a crazy
conclusion to think Tom delayed the
video. I don't think it happened
necessarily, but I don't think it's a
crazy conclusion.
I'm intentionally delayed his response
to serious rape allegations so Nick
could cover it and bash Chud while he
was on vacation so he couldn't
immediately respond.
You are a sad strange little man, and
you have my pity. Farewell.
Bro, imagine having to wait for me to go
away to talk [__] about me. What an
insane amount of power this would
witness, bro.
I mean, that's true either way, whether
Tom
delayed the video or not. It is
absolutely true that Nick waited for Tom
to go away to talk [__] That's
absolutely true.
Millions have left, dude. They've all
[__] unsubscribed. I've lost 600 subs
since I've been on holiday, dude.
How is that malicious, bro?
I am responding. Dude, this idea that
I'm some [__] snake, this idea that
I'm some [__] snake when people are
waiting till I go on holiday
to start talking all this [__] [__]
about me. Are you [__] serious, dude?
Yeah, yeah. So, I Jar is now mixed up
two different claims. The idea that they
waited with a response here that Nick
waited to talk [__]
I don't necessarily think they waited
for the response, but Nick did wait to
talk [__] cuz Nick could have said any
opinions he had about the the big sweep
stuff. Could have made that totally
clear.
That happened. That didn't require Tom
to respond for him to take issue with in
the way that he did.
Dude, literally, what have I done wrong
here?
What have I done wrong? He waited for
Turkey Tom's response so he could create
this impression that I'd been undermined
by it, which is ridiculous, as you'll
see in a minute, okay?
And then he obviously waited until I was
away so that he could launch his attack
against me, right? Say all the [__] that
he wanted about me, and then go, "Yep,
that's dealt with. Bridge burnt." And
then not have to deal with any of the
[__] blowback. What's pathetic, bro?
What is truly pathetic
is waiting till I go on holiday to talk
all this [__] about me, and then when I
come back and respond, you're sat in
your Discord of [__] retards seething
about me like you've been doing for
months. Like you've been doing for
months, apparently. Yet Chudlogic and
his fans have this weird thing about his
vacation, acting like you can't make a
video on him or respond to anything
while he's away. You knew no I don't
think anyone Anyone else says that.
I don't think anyone says that. It's
just true that Nick absolutely did wait
so that he didn't have to deal with the
response.
You can do that, but you're a total
[__] if you do.
No one thinks it's some evil act.
I don't I mean, Chud sometimes acts like
it. Chud Chud sometimes especially in
the presence of this stuff, it's like,
"Oh, well, I went on holiday. Well, I
went on holiday." You know, he does do
that.
But no one else is actually making the
argument that like, "Oh, you can't You
can't do it while someone's on holiday.
You can't release stuff while someone's
on holiday." No, it just It is the case
that Nick, because he's a
conflict-avoidant [__]
waited until Chud was on holiday so that
he could deal with less blowback.
Know that Chud can just respond right
when he gets back, right? Responding to
something immediately or a week later
doesn't really change anything. Acting
like I was doing something sus when Mhm.
No, it does, especially in streaming.
No, it does. Responding while Chud was
on vacation is one thing. Granted, I
didn't know the guy was going on
vacation. I don't
>> Oh, I see what's happening here. He got
the same [__] He got the same [__]
Okay. follow the guy or pay attention to
him or stalk him like a weirdo. But
acting like Tom delayed his response to
serious allegations so someone else
could bash Chud while he was away
>> think that. But Nick did wait. Nick did
wait. Again, I keep saying
it does not rely on Tom re- uh delaying
the video for Nick to have waited to
talk [__] because he could have said all
the things that he said day one.
That's one of the most insane cope I
have ever heard in my life. Oh, you got
me.
By all accounts, it doesn't make sense.
Hey, Tom, could I talk to you for a
minute? Oh, yeah, Nick, what is it? I
got to respond to these allegations
quick. No, Tom, delay it by a few days.
Chud's about to go on vacation. But,
Nick, these are serious allegations that
could totally ruin my life, and Chud is
a nobody compared to me. What would him
even responding a few days later even
change? Listen, Tom, he said the big
sweep might be on.
Oh god, why didn't you just start with
that? Yeah, when you think about Chud's
conspiracy for more than 5 seconds, it
sounds absolutely insane. And Chud would
go on and on about this conspiracy
multiple times throughout his video,
even accusing people of saying that
going after him while he was on vacation
was a noble act.
Ah, [__] man. [__] I can't make posts.
[__] Even though no one ever said that.
Since when did it become a noble act
[__] [__] to be a bunch of [__]
mean goes, right? Bro is shadow boxing
right now. He's finding [__] that isn't
even there.
Chud makes a claim that he doesn't like
to leak DMs. Guys, I was I was I was
trying to think of how to [__] you. [__]
you.
My word is my bond, okay?
[__] you. My word is my bond. And then
later he leaks DMs between him and Nick
that don't make Nick look bad at all.
Nick responds to Chud's response and
claims the W. To be fair, Nick had the
bigger audience and the bigger stomach,
so he was at a pretty big advantage from
the start, but Chud made things way too
easy for him. Yeah, I have done that
little mistake. [__] you.
I just I want I want to
It's hard to convey your opinion,
you know?
It's hard to convey your opinion on
certain things sometimes. But at that
point, people pretty much stopped
caring, and Chud lost several
subscribers. Chud's little friends tried
to defend him and attack Nick, but they
didn't really do any damage and kind of
just hurt themselves in the process.
It's pretty clear to most people that
you can lose a battle, but still win a
battle, but it's important to know that
you can lose a battle, but still win. If
you're If you're on the uh the Queen of
Instagram private story, you'll be
you'll you'll know about this, guys,
okay? Nicholas DeOrio now had more
enemies, and just like a Republican
candidate who had victory in the palm of
his hands, refused to get out of his own
way. Nicholas did a video on Anisa
Chomou, and he made a really stupid take
that a lot of his enemies noticed. I'm a
big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I
say? You do your research.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know. I know. Not only is that
offensive, it's also bad. Like, it's a
bad impression. Holy gee willikers, I'm
sure happy that the guy with the
ultimate rape review hat is telling us
what is and isn't offensive. He tried to
walk back on this saying he was making a
hypocritical
>> Jar. W Jar. completely post hoc cope.
You would not get that implication by
watching this clip or the following clip
after it. If anyone's the hypocrite
here, it's [__] Nicholas. He was
saying that it's too offensive to make
fun of someone's voice while wearing an
ultimate rape review hat. And the best
part is Nicholas in the past also made
fun of Hila's voice and the way she
looked. No, but do you hear Tommy do the
Hila Klein voice and [__] like that? He
did that today. You guys hear this
tonight? Uh [__] Tommy gets on there
and goes,
Hey, Keemstar.
So, Thing is, his is worse. His sucks.
His is a worse impression.
Tommy has a really good Yo, we're going
to get Tommy to start doing Tommy has a
really good
I still don't understand why Tommy's
Israel
>> You're not supposed to hate Jar at this
point. Nobody [__] cares about making
a bad video defending someone who did
something,
you know, bad two two [__] years ago.
No one cares. racist. I don't get it.
Okay. It's funny to me.
I was in the middle
>> strong hatred of Jar, you're losing
heavily. wondering why Keemstar is so
mean to people. The fact of the matter
is Hila Klein actually sounds like that.
So, the my officers and like the the
soldiers in that brigade, um they would
go every night on a raid Right. in
Ramadi to to arrest terrorists, and um
so I always saw them preparing for it
and leaving, and then I I would stay in
the base. Mhm. So, one time I wanted to
go with them.
>> [laughter]
>> It's funny cuz it's true.
>> Of course, Nicholas has also done this
to other people like xQc, who has one of
the most bizarre speaking patterns I've
ever heard in my life. Imagine going to
xQc, and you're like, "Hey, dude, what
are you going TO COVER TODAY?"
LIKE, WHAT DO WHAT DO YOU EXPECTING
[__] xQc to say about JFK's
assassination? Nothing. But I'm pretty
sure you guys have I've this point
plenty of times already. But I have a
unique point of my own about how much
Nicholas [__] sucks off Ethan Klein.
Nicholas
>> Let's hear it. me. The dude has made
dozens upon dozens of videos about me.
He'll even bring me up in videos that
have nothing to do with me. Like this
video he made on that one Christian
Peanut. Fart into it? Nah, I just
farted. Spicy hot diarrhea?
Ooh, okay, yeah. Now this is Dude, this
is like POV Jars DMs. Or this video he
made on the Alt-Right Playbook guy where
he's bitching and moaning about no
longer being motivated to make YouTube
videos right after e-begging so much
that he made enough money to pay off his
taxes. Why is this video so [__]
ugly? Why is it just like spread [__]
text? What is happening?
>> for signs.
>> What like random BoJack Horseman footage
behind it?
>> You will find them. Dude, this is like a
40-minute video. It's ass ugly. Be
thankful that you're watching my [__]
It's catharsis. But you are the author,
not the universe. You narrative It's
art. No, dude, this is This is fart,
bro. is the path. This is fart tent, not
art tent. test. And that's how you write
your future. Can you believe this video
is being uploaded on the same channel as
like Not the same channel, but like the
same platform where Just a Robot posts?
And I actually don't know which video is
more pathetic. I don't know which video
of mine Nicholas is referring to. He's
being very vague about it, but I think
this guy is a little bit more pathetic
than
>> He just thinks it Well, I got
He just thinks it's an easy win. He
thinks it's an easy dunk. He's just
like, "Oh, Jar, [__] Jar, [__] Jar." Cuz
he he thinks Jar won't respond and won't
be able to respond in a compelling way
so he can just endlessly make dunks on
Jar. Like he does with Tipster, Bo
Bucks, anyone.
And all of this up is it to [__] and
whine that he's just so mean to me? Ha,
no. I'm bringing it up to show that he
hates almost every single video I make.
He'll constantly bring me up and that
he'll never agree with me on anything.
Unless, of course, I'm defending Ethan
Klein. If I go after Ethan's detractors
like iDubbz, Nicholas will still find a
way to disagree with me. But if I'm
defending Ethan directly like in my
video on Cruel World Happy Mind,
Nicholas absolutely loves it. Haha. talk
[__] about me at the start of the video,
but once we get to the parts of me
defending Ethan Klein, he will give me
praise upon praise upon praise. I was
exactly as edgy in my iDubbz video as I
was in this video, but because I'm
defending H3, Nicholas is forced to
defend me. After all, Nicholas is a
>> [laughter]
>> good boy, and he wouldn't do anything
Daddy wouldn't like. Hey, stop it.
Get some help.
>> After being wrecked for a while and not
Is Jar winning? Is Jar just winning
here?
Is he unstoppable?
worm her way out of responsibility, she
just kind of laid down and took a stern
talking to like she was a daughter
getting disciplined by her parents for
sleeping with too many guys. She kept
repeating her points talking about
personal [__] and saying that she has to
be better moving forward. This is like
the weirdest video I've watched in a
really long time and it's breaking my
mind that it's just a robot. Look at ALL
THAT CAP. NO!
NO!
POP [__] ON the Dude, this is insane.
This is crazy. I I'm actually kind of
nervous to hear what he's going to say
about Adam McIntyre. walls. This guy's
room or booth or whatever literally
looks the same as a 14-year-old girl's.
I mean, he's right. And I know this
because a long time ago I had a friend
whose sister's room looked exactly like
this. I don't care if you're gay. Dude,
this is [__] This is [__]
embarrassing. Basically, he says some
[__] that amounts [music] to something
something I started a war I couldn't win
or something something I'm a victim and
also gay. Oh, Jesus [__] Christ, Jar.
>> [laughter]
>> Holy [__] dude. I didn't expect this.
This is like Unironically, this is
significantly funnier than this video
that he tried to make on iDubbz. I did
not expect this at all. I don't even
know what I I I I'm just completely
Nicholas, calm down. You're going to
break your arm jerking me off. those
standards See, look, there's the
nodding. All right, it's not aggressive
nodding, but he just just sits there
[__] nodding.
>> There's even Yeah, yeah, yeah. order to
provide the most accurate information.
What do you mean your research is
getting better?
The thing is well, I don't know what Jar
even said in this video. I don't think I
watched this cuz I didn't cover all the
Cruel World Happy Mind [__] There is
like no way Nick can justify it. So
crazy they justify going after Adam
McIntyre
when the whole thing they do the whole
the whole like
impetus for defending Ethan is
he had his family [__] with. He CPS
calls.
They
the Snark subreddit was posting like
report confirmed [__] of like ice
reports they were doing against Adam
McIntyre.
There is a issue There is no way to
square your position on these two
issues.
So, I don't know like
Yeah, Jar's just sitting here and
mocking Adam McIntyre and that might be
totally consistent with [__] Jar says.
I've got no idea. I haven't watched
enough of his videos.
Um
but it's not for Nick. It's not for
Nick. The idea that he's just totally
accepting this is totally inconsistent
with what he says. But obviously because
it's a
uh uh pro-Ethan video he's going to turn
off all critical thinking like we saw
with Lion the Box earlier. Not even
going to push back on the parts that he
should disagree with. It's just Oh,
yeah, this is amazing video cuz Ethan
Ethan epic Ethan epic. It worse before?
I'm not watching this bitch's old
videos, but
>> [laughter]
>> and this hard. You know how bad things
have to be that Jar understands this?
This is something This doesn't get
through to like
Just a robot has figured it out. That's
crazy.
Okay, what are the chances that if we go
and find what Jar is saying in that
instance, it's [__]
Just a robot has figured it out. That's
crazy. I'm shocked at how much this this
this is killing me. This actually is
This is his best video he's ever made.
And there his arm goes. He even titled
his original stream on this something
along the lines of Jar's Redemption Arc
before he changed it. Obviously, he did
this because his fans wouldn't stop
tearing him apart. Bro is totally
audience captured. Now you could make
the argument [laughter] that maybe
Nicholas DeOrio just really liked this
specific video of mine. Yeah, out of the
10 plus videos of
cautionist or anything. He's not that
cool, but he is Jack No, no, no. videos
of mine he has covered and gave a
negative review of.
She was surrounded from all [music]
sides on this. So when Ethan and Hila
invited her onto the But all of this
negative attention was the first time
Barbie ever got it on went hard enough.
To be fair though
>> Oh, so yeah, it's it's that part where
he's saying basically that um
the H3 snarkers don't think he that she
went hard enough. Um so she's
[__] herself by getting attacked on
all angles. I'm shocked at how much this
this this is killing me. This actually
is This is his best video he's ever
made. And there his arm goes. He even
titled his original stream on this
something along the lines of Jar's
Redemption Arc before he changed No, it
wasn't 6:10. It was 6:50. It was 6:50.
It was a different frame that I was
looking at. He did this because his fans
wouldn't stop tearing him apart. Bro is
totally audience captured. Now you could
make the argument that maybe Nicholas
DeOrio just really liked this specific
video of mine. Yeah, out of the 10 plus
videos of mine he has covered and gave a
negative review of, he just so happened
to like the one where I was defending
H3H3. What a coincidence. Wow. Now this
is a very common pattern of behavior
with Nick. When he likes another
YouTuber and becomes friends with them,
if anyone attacks him in any way, he
becomes a sensitive little [__] about
it. He acts like an anime YouTuber after
someone said something negative about
Lolly. So that's why I'm going to show
this clip from DeAngelo Wallace.
Probably the best of which was the
YouTuber Nicholas DeOrio telling me that
he unpinned my comment on his YouTube
video because I'm I'm just as bad as I'm
Alex. I get what he's trying to imply in
his YouTube video.
Dude, what is this [__] tweet?
I just unpinned this and you can shove
it up your ass. Here's what much of a
degenerate as Alex.
So estrogenic, man.
Jesus. I'm I'm just as bad as I'm Alex.
I get what he's trying to imply, but I'm
Alex. Falsely accuse somebody of
assault. So that's like comparing apples
to oranges. And besides
unpinning a comment, that's the best you
could come up with? Okay. What do you
think was going through Nicholas's mind
when he posted this tweet?
>> I don't like this guy anymore. He's
going after my friend. You know what?
I'm going to unpin his comment and I'm
going to tell him that I did it.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, that will show him. What a zinger.
I'm surprised he didn't send DeAngelo to
heaven without
>> do realize why Nick doesn't get in
direct fights. You really do start
realizing why he doesn't even try at
this point. Why Nick? No for this and
Tonka, it's just For a few of you who
don't know the context as to what's
going on, basically DeAngelo called
Turkey Tom racist for saying that he
wanted to kill all the tiggers, but
replace the T in the word tiggers with
the letter N. No, we got it. We got it.
a Nazi and a white nationalist. I called
him racist for saying I hate
It's not that serious. Of course, Nick
ran to Tom's defense. And this escalated
to the point where he was accusing
DeAngelo of some wild [__] I think the
worst tweet out of all though was this
one right here. Once again from the
>> rehashing this DeAngelo Wallace [__]
dude. That's just awesome. Like why?
DeOrio. Send your audience. Tell them I
said things I didn't. Have them flag my
Twitter down like you're clearly trying
to do with Tom. Really? First of all, if
I did somehow get his Twitter taken
down, you realize literally everyone
would hate me, right? Secondly, if me
tweeting about someone and tagging them
in the tweet is me trying to get their
account taken down, then that means
everyone tweeting about me right now is
trying to take my account down. Does
that make literally any sense
whatsoever? You're just putting words in
my mouth and it makes you SEEM REALLY
DUMB.
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> I HATE LIKE THE TV SHOW movie edits and
[__] that is so lame but
I mean the clip was funny.
Nicholas DeOrio has a habit of
commenting on other people's
relationships like iDubbz relationship,
other people's relationship and even my
relationship. Didn't he say that his
girlfriend was going to dump him if he
makes a drama video? That's weird my
last five videos have been drama
adjacent and she's still with me. Fact
of the matter is I don't do ultimatums
in relationships. Of course if Nick
wants to talk about other people's
relationship then he's more than welcome
to but if you're going to throw stones
you shouldn't live in a glass house.
Nick you have some nerve commenting on a
relationship. Last I checked your love
life is a pile of [__] My last video
was on internet blood sports. It's
probably my best video ever and you guys
should totally check it out. The reason
I bring this up is because I had to do a
lot of research into different YouTubers
one of which was TonkaSaw and I found
this clip between him and Nicholas
DeOrio. A lot of people A lot of people
have been finding this clip recently it
seems like. I was crying. When did the
tears come out of your eyes? Probably
when that girl said she wasn't your
girlfriend on that post. That was the
saddest [__] I've ever seen. What girl
said she wasn't my girlfriend?
>> When you posted a picture of you holding
somebody's hand
just trying to be vague about it and
then they're like you have a girlfriend
and the girl's like no no no he's my
best friend. Dude you have no idea what
you're talking That was funny as [__]
No that was funny as [__] Okay so that
didn't happen Nick. Nick did that happen
or not? Yeah it absolutely happened. You
posted a vague picture of you holding
somebody's hand or like [__] some
[__] and then the do you have a
girlfriend? She's like no no no he's my
best friend and not my girlfriend. Do
not talk about my [__] personal life
on here. I do not It's not your personal
life. It's a tweet you made. It's a
tweet you made Nick. He's such a [__]
Nick it's a tweet you made that's not
your personal life.
It's a tweet you made. It's not your
personal life. It's a tweet not your
personal life dork. Oh wow. You think
it's cool to talk I I I intentionally
don't name people like this
>> Oh my god. specifically cuz I keep that
part of my life very off the internet.
No you don't. You tried to post it and
look cool and you didn't look cool. It
was her idea to make the [__] post in
the first place. I told her that I'm
sure it was.
That's none of your [__] business.
Then why'd you post it on Twitter Nick?
It's none of my business. Why is it up
there Nick? Why'd you post it if it's
none of anybody's business?
How is this your PERSONAL LIFE NICK?
BECAUSE IT'S FUNNY REMEMBER? IT'S ABOUT
things that are funny. We're debating.
We're debating Nick is that what's
happening?
OH DID NICK
>> [laughter]
>> BRO JUST RAGE QUIT. Nicholas DeOrio has
made entire videos commenting on other
people's relationships but as soon as he
gets pressured on one of his
relationships he rage quits. Bro is
absolutely a glass cannon. He can dish
it out but he can't take it. I really do
love
>> And it's not even like it's like
relationship stuff. It's [__] he posted.
He elected to post stuff that he put on
his main account front facing content
creator Twitter account. How can you
even complain that you what what is your
ground to [__] [__] about that? How
he tries to shift the blame and say oh
it's her idea. Bro she was the one who
commented on it to correct the record.
For context Nicholas DeOrio posted this
picture of him with a girl at VidCon. Aw
they're clinking glasses together how
romantic. Probably the closest Nick ever
got to first base. Some guy replied to
this tweet with I guess you have a
girlfriend. [music] The girl in question
replies to this tweet with we aren't
dating but he's my best friend. Ooh
friend zoned. And Nicholas DeOrio
replies with shh women.
Women.
>> [laughter]
>> To everybody watching this video do you
guys think this was her idea because it
really doesn't look that way to me. Who
knows maybe it was her idea so she could
publicly humiliate Nick. I do love how
triggered he gets over people talking
about his personal life a personal life
he made public himself when he has
literally done 10 times worse to
multiple different people. I have to
wonder do you guys think that Nick gets
any like any at all?
Well apparently he's got a girlfriend he
took with him to VidCon and Bo Blacks
were saying that she's fat as [__] so
who knows man. I do and I'm just a
robot.
He said it. He said it. Jar [__] more
than Nick. Elon predicted we would be
having sex with robots by 2025. Is it
almost endearing when Jar like when
anyone else does this sort of thing it's
like that's cringe. Is it almost
endearing when Jar does it? I think it's
I think it might almost be endearing
when Jar when Jar does it. When do you
[__] think people will have sex with
Nick by the year 2525?
Nick if you're watching this let me give
you some dating advice. Yes you are
going to get dating advice from Mr. Jay
himself. First get into her DMs and then
ask her if she wants to see a picture of
your [__] and then after that Send a
picture of a chicken. of a chicken. This
is foolproof it's never failed once. You
know maybe this is why Nick is batting
so hard for Ethan Klein. A lot of the
girls on his subreddit seem to think
that Nick is hot. Maybe selling out for
a Jew is the only way for this dude to
get [__] but Nicholas DeOrio's sleepy
time calls at VidCon are not his only
stories he has with VidCon. I need to
come clean about something. I told a lot
of people that I was working on a video
about Bo Blacks but as I was working on
it I kind of got bored and just made a
video on internet blood sports. So sorry
everyone I'm no longer making that video
on Bo Blacks. But as I was doing
research for that video I came across
this clip. For context after a Nick and
Bobby's falling out where Nick
completely destroyed Bo Blacks a few of
Bo Blacks friends confronted Nicholas
DeOrio at VidCon. One of them was Net
Loss and he stole Nicholas DeOrio's $600
glasses.
So I walked up to him and I introduced
myself. I go I'm the
>> [laughter]
>> bad Nick that you're saving everybody
from and he goes what? I go you know
you're you're saving all these Nicks out
there and one of them said I'm not
shaking your hand.
I'm not shaking your hand.
>> [laughter]
>> He owned me.
And then he No but then he gets right in
my face and he goes You know if I had a
nickel for every time a drama YouTuber
freaked out over a handshake at VidCon I
would have two nickels which isn't a lot
but it's weird that it's happened twice.
He's like I don't like you and I'm like
oh
okay. Like so wait what are you going to
do about it? And he's like and then I
>> [laughter]
>> Then I just called him a slur.
I'm like you're acting like a slur right
now. Oh thank god Nick only called him
an acronym for a freaky alien genotype.
At least he didn't make fun of the guy's
voice because that would have been a
step too far. I'm joking of course Nick
still made fun of the guy's voice who
actually sounds like this in real life.
You see this light down here? It's an
automatic AI Yeah he literally he is
actually he is actually saying some of
the comments on I light it tracks me I
got an automatic tracking crew right?
And it's shaking its head at me as I
film this video. It clearly must have
sensors in it that are like oh no no no
don't talk about her data collection but
data collection is what they do not that
thing but other things definitely do.
Nick can say what he wants about Anisa's
impression of Hila but it was way more
spot on than Net Loss.
Honestly now I'm starting to think that
he just took offense to the fact that
she's better at doing impressions than
him.
>> [laughter]
>> So he snatched my glasses off my face
and started dancing seductively at me.
So I followed him for like two seconds
and I realized he's not turning around
and then I walked back.
>> connects. So Net Loss literally went up
to Nicholas DeOrio and ripped his
sunglasses off his face. If someone did
that to me Re that Re that me artist
impression artist impression. DeOrio and
ripped his sunglasses off his face. If
someone did that to me or most men I
know I would just beat the [__] out of
them and yeah that would be in your
legal right. If someone takes something
off of you that can legally be
classified as assault. Yes I did learn
that from Legal Eagle's worst video.
They're prescription you can have them
back. I'm like yeah thanks for my $600
glasses [__] Yeah but if you
try to take my glasses or he
did he just going to get smacked bro
that's not my fault it's your fault.
[laughter] You got to understand I'm in
like an aura right now like Yeah that's
not how that went down. Nick probably
said oh yo please give them back they're
my prescription glasses and Net Loss
feeling bad for the blind bat gave him
his glasses back. Nick if you're
watching this video
Nick is a fat kid with prescription
glasses. Where's the aura? Where's the
aura at all? Oh jeez I had too much aura
to take them back myself. Yeah sure
whatever you say Carl Weathers. There
are some other small annoying things
that Nicholas DeOrio does like randomly
going on tangents about either
>> [laughter]
>> Not good. Not good. In my video on Cru
World Happy Mind I brought up Magneto
for like 10 to 20 seconds. Nicholas
DeOrio talked about him for a solid five
minutes. Also if Nicholas doesn't like
you bro will talk about you forever.
I've already shown that he's brought up
me If he thinks this is an easy fight if
he thinks this is an easy fight. he
randomly but he's done the same to Bo
Blacks, Tipster and even John Swan.
Who? Bro it's been over a half a decade.
Let it go. Also outside of Argi ARFC,
Turkey Tom, Nicholas DeOrio and Bo
Blacks no one gives a [__] about
Tipster. A common complaint about me is
that I bring up past dramas too often.
Shut the [__] up Nicholas DeOrio is 10
times worse than me. If you look up
Nicholas DeOrio on YouTube That's just
true. We did all mock Jar
for constantly doing the thing where you
just reference
old dramas and like everything is a
point about old
Nick is way worse for it. Nick is
actually worse than Jar.
That is actually true. That is actually
true. And we that is one of the places
where we first started mocking it was
cuz of Jar. But you'll see more people
making videos on him now than probably
ever before. But it seemed like most
people sided with him in his fight with
Bo Blacks or his fight with Chud Logic
so what happened? Well it's because Nick
was cozying up to H3H3. A lot of people
do love the guy but a lot of people also
hate him and thanks to Nick's little
roll in the mud with Chud Logic which
also made a lot of the other commentary
bros turn on Nick as well. Who does Nick
really have in his corner anymore? Well,
there's Augie and that's about it. Drama
YouTubers are sharks and currently
there's blood in the water. Nick is
currently avoiding the drama surrounding
him, meaning that his low cow gene
hasn't really quite activated yet. He
still has a very good chance of turning
everything around and getting out of
this mess. Even as I'm recording this,
people are still making more videos on
Nick, pointing out the fact that as soon
as Anisa Chomos are talking about him,
he stopped covering her because Nick
spineless little [__] who only goes
after a low hanging fruits. To be fair.
Okay. To be fair.
No, to be fair. With how fat and short
he is, I think he can only reach the low
hanging fruits. Ultimately, most of the
stuff people have against Chud and Nick
is pretty small potatoes. Yeah, Chud
took a
hit to his viewer
count, but he's already starting to get
back into the algorithm. Nick hasn't
really taken any damage at all and he's
kind of just ignoring everything. Think
about what other streamers like Vaush,
Destiny, and Hasan have done. They're
doing perfectly fine and they have done
way more [__] than both Nicholas DeOrio
and Chud Logic combined. I do think it's
absolutely hilarious that Turkey Tom
gets falsely accused of rape and
everybody else suffers. Trust me, Nick
and Chud are just the tip of the
iceberg, but that's a video for another
time.
>> [music]
>> Wow, what a great video What a great
video from Jahl there.
Thank Jahl respect button.